érigé en sésame le passeport vaccinale
fait l'objet de nombreux débats et
l'union européenne ne fait pas exception
la commission a dévoilé son projet de
certificats numériques en mars dernier
gratuit ce certificat prendrait la forme
d'un document doté d'un qr code a
présenté lors des contrôles dans les
pays membres
quel que soit le moyen de transport
utilisé le 29 avril le parlement
européen s'est déjà prononcé en faveur
du dispositif
mais c'est à présent aux états membres
du conseil européen qu'il revient de
ratifier le projet avec la
multiplication des initiatives
nationales en termes de passes
sanitaires l'enjeu est bien d'éviter une
véritable cacophonie européenne
de nombreux états membres ont lancé ou
prévoient de lancer des initiatives
visant à délivrer des certificats de
vaccination
toutefois pour que ces certificats
puisse être utilisé de manière efficace
dans un contexte transfrontières lorsque
le citoyen exercent leur droit à la
libre circulation
ces certificats de vaccination doivent
être pleinement intéropérables
compatible sur et vérifiable une
approche adoptée d'un commun accord
entre les états membres est nécessaire
pour ce qui est du contenu du format des
principes des normes techniques et du
niveau de protection de ces certificats
si cet outil visera surtout à faciliter
la vie des européens selon la commission
il ne parvient pas encore à convaincre
la totalité des états membres les pays
du sud dépendant du tourisme comme la
grèce se sont montrés parmi les premiers
favorables à sa mise en place
mais d'autres se montrent plus réticents
parmi les sujets d'inquiétude la
protection des données des utilisateurs
ou encore l'aspect discriminatoire du
certificat valable uniquement pour les
quatre vaccins autorisés par l' agence
européenne des médicaments il exclurait
ainsi les citoyens de pays comme la
hongrie la slovaquie ou la pologne qui
ont reçu des doses de 6
au farm le sérum chinois ou de spoutnik
v le vaccin russe qui n'a toujours pas
été autorisé au niveau européen
l' agence européenne des médicaments qui
procède à l'enregistrement de tous les
médicaments retarde l'enregistrement de
scouts nick v je ne peux pas blâmer les
experts et spécialistes de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
mais nous savons avec certitude que ce
retard est dû à des signaux que leur
donne des personnes haut placées de
l'union européenne quoi qu'il en soit
les états membres restent souverains
dans la gestion de leurs frontières
intérieures
ils pourront donc définir d'autres
contours et usages à ce document la
commission elle espère aboutir à un
accord avant la saison touristique
estivale d'ici fin juin
si cette preuve de vaccination
standardisés réussissait à voir le jour
bruxelles devra encore toutefois se
confronter à une autre problématique
celle d'éviter les fraudes et le
développement d'un marché noir
à l'échelle européenne